The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK, let me get going.
Last time we were talking
about multi-particle states
and tensor products.
And for that, we
explained that if we
have a system, a quantum
mechanical system of one
particle described
by a vector space V,
and the quantum mechanical
system of another particle
described with a vector space
W, the quantum mechanics
of the total system composed
by the two particles
is defined on a new vector space
called the space V tensor W.
And that was a construction that
showed that in particular it
was not true to say
that, oh if you want
to know the system
of particle 1 and 2,
you just tell me what
state particle 1 is
and what state particle
2 is, and that's
the end of the story.
No, the story is really more
sophisticated than that.
So the typical
elements on this space
were of the form
aij vi cross wj.
And it's a sum over i and j
numbers times these vectors.
So you pick a vector
in the first vector
space, a vector in the
second vector space,
you put them in here and take
linear combinations of them.
So that's the general
state in the system.
Now we said a few
things about this.
One thing I didn't
say too much about
was the issue of the vector
0 in this tensor space.
And well, vector 0 is some
element of any vector space
is an important element.
And we could get a little
confused about how it looks.
And here's for example,
the vector 0 in v cross w.
An example of the vector 0
is the vector 0 tensor wi.
If you put in the first input,
the vector 0, that's it.
That is also the
vector 0 in here.
Vi tensor the vector 0 in w.
Here is 0 in w.
Here is 0 in v. This is also 0.
It's maybe a little surprising.
Now how do we see that?
Well we had a property.
For example, this one. av tensor
w is equal to av tensor w,
where a is a number.
So pick a equals 0.
Well 0 times any
vector is the 0 vector.
0 cross w.
But 0 times any vector
is also the vector 0.
So this is the 0 in v cross w.
So 0 cross w is the vector 0.
Once you put 0 in one of the
two inputs, you're there.
You're at 0.
You don't have more.
So that's just a
comment on the vector 0.
Now we did a few things.
And one thing I
didn't do last time
was to define an inner product
on the new vector space.
So let's define a
way to get numbers
from one vector in
the tensor space
and another vector
in the tensor space.
So inner product.
And again, here you're
supposed to define it
to your best
understanding and the hope
that, once you make
the right definitions,
it has all that axiomatic
properties it should have.
So let me take the
following thing.
The inner product
with this thing aij
vi omega j with bpq vp wq.
So I will define
this by assuming
the linearity in the
inputs on the right inputs
and the anti-linearity
here on the left input.
So this would be the
sum over inj here.
So I'll put sum over
inj aij star sum
over pq bpq and then
vi wj comma vp wq.
So by declaring that
this is the case,
I'm saying that the inner
product in the tensor space
has the-- I'm demanding it has
the properties that we expect.
If you have a vector plus
another vector here, well
you get this times the first
plus this times the second.
So you can take the sums
out and arrange it this way.
But I still haven't
got a number,
and the inner product is
supposed to be a number.
So how do we get a
number at this stage?
I have this thing,
and nobody has told me
what this is supposed to be.
At this stage, the
only thing you can say
is, well, you know
I suspect that, if I
had an inner product in V and
I had an inner product in w,
I must have an
inner product here,
and somehow I should use that.
So they still define
to be ij pq aij bpq.
And then what you do is
use the inner product in v
to get a number from
these two vectors.
This is going the
v inner product.
And use the inner product on w
to get a number from the two w
vectors.
And that's it.
The end of the definition.
Now here maybe this is the sort
of most interesting step, where
this part was set equal to this.
And consistent with what
I was telling you about 0,
suppose any of this vi was 0.
If this vi was 0, we
would have 0 with vp.
That would be 0, so
this whole number is 0.
So the way this
can happen is one
of the vectors must be 0 here.
And well, you have
the 0 vector here,
and the zero vector inner
product with anything is 0.
So it's, again,
consistent to think
that, once you put one
of these entries to 0,
you've got the 0 vector.
So where are we going today?
Well, we have now
the inner product,
and I want to go back to
a state we had last time.
What we're going to
do today is define
what we called an
entangled state.
Then we will consider
basis of entangled states,
and we will be able to discuss
this sort of nice example
of teleportation,
quantum teleportation.
So that's where
we're going today.
I wanted to remind
you of a calculation
we were doing last time.
We had established that there
was a state in the tensor
product of 2 spin 1/2 particles.
And the state was alpha
plus tensor minus minus
minus tensor plus.
Now you can sometimes-- this is
an example of a superposition
of vectors of the
from in the v cross w.
So here is a vector
of that form.
There is a vector of this form.
Sometimes we put here 1 and 2.
And sometimes it will be
useful to put those labels.
Because if you don't
put the labels,
you better make sure
that you're always
talking that the first ket, is
the one for the first vector
space, and the second ket is
the one for the second vector
space.
There's nothing really
known commutative here.
So if somebody would
write for you 1 minus 2,
or they would write
minus 2 1, both of you
would be talking
about the same state.
But if you don't
put the labels, you
know you're not something
about the same state,
because you assume
always the first one goes
to the first Hilbert space.
The second one goes with
the second vector space.
So we considered an
entangled state of two
spin 1/2 particles.
I'm not using-- it's not fair
to use the word entangled yet,
but we'll be able to
say this very soon.
So the one thing we can do
now given the inner product
is try to normalize this state.
So how do we
normalize this state?
Well, we must take the
inner product of this state
with itself.
So psi psi.
So then what do we do?
Well, given these
rules, we're supposed
to take all this vector
here, all that vector there,
1 alpha-- the alpha
that is on the left
goes out as an alpha star.
The alpha that this on the
right goes out as an alpha.
And we have plus minus minus
minus plus inner product
with plus minus
minus minus plus.
Now this is easier than what
it seems from what I'm writing.
You will be able to do
these things, I think.
Or you can already maybe
do them by inspection.
Basically at this
stage, you have
to do each one
with each one here.
And let's see what we get.
Well, what is the inner
product of this with this?
This works, because the inner
product of plus with plus is 1
and minus with minus is 1.
This on the other hand,
doesn't give any contribution,
because the first
one is a plus has
0 inner product with a minus.
A minus has 0 with a plus.
That doesn't matter.
It's an overkill.
So this one couples with this,
and this one couples with that.
Another way people
would do this is
to say oh don't worry
just take the bra here.
So it's plus minus.
Here is one.
I'll put the labels too.
Minus the bra of the minus
is the minus like that.
1 plus 2.
And now you do
this with this ket,
the plus minus 1 2 minus
the minus plus 1 2.
And bras and kets, you know that
this one goes with this one.
Plus plus, minus minus,
And here I put the labels,
because when I form the bra,
it's not obvious which
one you would put first,
but it doesn't really matter.
So back here, we have
norm of alpha squared.
And this with this is 1.
And minus is one,
this is another one.
So this is 2 alpha squared.
So if I want it to be
normalized, I take alpha 1
over square root of 2.
And this is the well
normalized state.
So this is the unit
So we have this state.
This state is something you've
played with over last week.
Is that state that
we started very fine
in lecture that had 0 z
component of angular momentum,
0 x component of
angular momentum,
and 0 y component
of angular momentum.
Total angular momentum
as we defined it.
And this has a state with
absolutely no angular momentum.
And what you verified
in the homework
was that that state, in fact,
is rotational invariant.
You apply a rotation
operator to that state
by rotating in both spaces,
and out comes the same state.
The state is not changed.
So it's a very interesting state
that will be important for us
later.
All right, so having taken
care of inner products
and normalizations, let's talk
a little about entangled states.
So entangled states.
So these are precisely those
states in which you cannot say,
or describe them by saying
particle one is doing this,
particle two is doing that.
You've learned that v cross w
includes a state superpositions
alpha ij vi cross omega j.
The question is, if somebody
hands you a state like this,
maybe you could do some
algebra or some trickery.
And is it equal, you ask, to
some sort of vector u star
tensor v star times
some vector w star.
Is it equal?
Is there vectors v star and
omega star belonging to v
and belonging to w in such a
way that this thing, the sum,
can be written as a product
of something and that.
If you would have that, then
you would be able to say look,
yes, this is an
interesting state,
but actually it's
all simple here.
Particle one is to state v star.
Particle two is in state w star.
If this has happened, if so,
this state of the two particles
is not entangled.
So if you can really factor
it, it's not entangled.
If there are no such
vectors v star and w star,
then it is entangled.
So you can say, well, it's
a complicated factorization
problem.
And indeed, it might
take a little work
to figure out if a state
is entangled or not.
It's not a basis
dependence problem.
It's not like it's entangled
in one basis or not.
Here is a state, and
you find any two things
that tensor this way
give you the state.
So the simplest
example to illustrate
this is two dimensional
vector spaces, v and w.
Two dimensional complex.
So v will have a
basis e1 and e2.
w will have a basis f1 and f2.
And the most general
state you could write
is a state, general state,
is a number a11 e1 f1
plus a2 e1 f2 plus a21
e2 f1 plus a22 e2 f2.
That's it.
There's two basis states
in v, two basis state in w.
v cross w is dimension for
product of dimensions for basis
states, the products of
the e's with the f's.
So that's it.
That's the general vector.
The question is if this
is it equal to something
like a1 e1 plus a2 e2.
Some general vector, you write
the most general vector in v,
and you write the most general
vector b1 f1 plus b2 f2 in w.
And you ask is it equal to
a product, tensor product,
of some vector in v
with some vector in w.
So the question is really
are their numbers a1, a2, b1,
and b2 so that this whole
thing gets factorized.
So that's happily not
a complicated problem.
We could see if
those number exist,
if a1, a2, b1, b2 exist, then
the state is not entangled.
You've managed to factor it out.
So let's see.
Well, we know the
distributive laws apply.
So actually e1 f1 can only
arise from this product.
So to have a solution
you must have
that a11 is equal to a1 b1.
a12 can only appear from
the product of e1 with f2.
So a12 must be equal to a1 b2.
a21 must be equal to a2 b2.
And a22 must be equal to a2 b2.
And we must try to solve
for these quantities.
Actually, there is a
consistency condition.
You see these quantities
repeat here in a funny way.
If this holds from this, a11 a22
minus a12 a21 is equal to what?
a11 a22 would be a1 b1 a2 b2.
And a12 a21 also
have the same things.
a1 b2 a2 b1.
Well, both terms have both a's
and both b's, so this system
only has a solution
if this product is 0.
So if you give me four numbers,
if you hope to factorize it,
you must have the
determinant of this matrix--
if you collapse it into a
matrix, a11 a12 a21 a22,
if you encode the information
about this state in a matrix,
it's necessary that the
determinant of the matrix a
be equal 0.
So the determinant
of a is equal to 0
is certainly necessary for the
factorization to take place.
But a very small argument
that will be in the notes,
or you can try to
complete it, shows
that the determinant
equal to 0, in fact,
guarantees that then you
can solve this system.
There's a solution.
And this is not complicated.
So determinant equals 0 is
actually the same as not
entangled.
We've done not entangled.
So there's a solution implies
determinant a equals 0,
but determinant of a equals
0 also implies not entangled.
You do that by solving this.
Let's not spend time doing that.
The basic way to do
it is to assume--
consider, say, a11
equals 0 and solve it.
Then a11 different
from 0, and then you
can show that you can
choose these quantities.
So it can be factored.
And you have that,
if these numbers are
such that the determinant is
0, then the state is entangled.
And it's very easy to have a
determinant of this non-zero.
For example, you could have
these two 0 and these two
non-zero.
That will be entangled because
the determinant is non-zero.
You can have this two
that will be entangled.
There are many ways of
getting entangled states.
So in fact, there's enough
ways to get entangled states
that we can construct a basis.
We had a basis here
of e1 f1 e2 f2.
This thing.
This four vector basis.
We can construct a basis
that is all the states,
all the basis vectors
are entangled states.
That's what we're
going to do next.
But maybe it's about
time for questions,
things that have become a
little unclear as I went along.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So what exactly
does an entangled state mean?
What are the [INAUDIBLE] to
give me an entangled state.
PROFESSOR: Well, the main
thing that it happens
is that there will be
interesting correlations when
you have an entangled state.
If you have an
entangled state and you
find a state that
is not entangled,
you can say particle
one is doing this
and particle two is doing that.
And particle two is
doing this independent
of what particle one is doing.
But when a state is
entangled, whatever
is happening with
particle one is
correlated with
what is happening
in particle two
in a strange way.
So if particle one
is doing something,
then particle two is
doing another thing.
But if particle one is
doing another thing,
then particle two
is doing something.
And these particles
can be very far apart,
and that's when it gets
really interesting.
So we're going to do a lot of
things with entangled states.
Today we're doing
this teleportation
using entangled state, and
you will see how subtle it is.
Next time we do EPR, these
Einstein Podolsky Rosen
arguments and the
Bell inequalities
that answered that
with entangled states.
There's a couple of problems
in the homework set also
developing entangled states
in different directions.
And I think by the
time we're done,
you'll feel very
comfortable with this.
So a basis of entangled states.
Here are those.
We're going to use spins.
So we're going to use v is
the state space of spin 1/2.
And we're going to
consider a v tensor
v where this refers to the
first particle and this
this to the second particle.
So let's take one
state, phi 0, defined
to be 1 over square root of
2, and I don't put indices.
And probably at
some stage, you also
tend to drop the tensor product.
I don't know if it's
early enough to drop it.
Probably we could drop it.
We'll put plus plus minus minus.
Of course, people eventually
drop even the other ket
and put it plus plus.
So those are the
evolutions of notation.
As you get to more and more
calculations, you write less,
but hopefully, it's still clear.
But I will not do this one.
I will still keep that
because many times,
I will want to keep labels.
Otherwise, it's a
little more cumbersome.
So this state is normalized.
Phi0 phi0 is equal to 1.
It's the state we built.
Oh, in fact, I want
it with a plus.
Sorry.
It's similar to the
state we had there.
And by now, you say, look,
yes, it's normalized.
Let's take the dual.
Plus plus with plus
plus will give me 1.
The minus minus with minus
minus will give me 1.
This is 2.
1 over square root
of 2 squared, 1.
It should become sort
of easy by inspection
that this is normalized.
And this is entangled
state because in the matrix
representation, it's a
1 here and a 1 there.
You have the 1 1 product
and the 2 2 product.
So 1 1, the determinant
is non-zero.
There's no way,
we've proven, you
can find how to factor this.
There's no alpha.
There's no way to write this as
an alpha plus, plus beta minus,
times a gamma plus,
plus delta minus.
Just impossible.
We've proven it.
It's entangled.
So this is an entangled
state, but the state space
is four dimensional.
So if it's four dimensional, we
need three more basis states.
So here they are.
I'm going to write
a formula for them.
Phi i for i equals
1, 2, and 3 will
be defined to be
the following thing.
You will act with the operator
1 tensor sigma i on phi 0.
So three ways of doing.
Let's do 1, for example, phi 1.
What is it?
Well, you would have 1 times
sigma 1 acting on the state phi
0, which is 1 over square
root of 2 plus, plus,
plus minus, minus.
Well, the 1 acts on the
first ket, the sigma
acts on the second ket.
So what do we get here?
1 over square root of 2-- let
me go a little slow-- plus
sigma 1 plus, plus,
minus sigma 1 minus.
And this is phi 1 equals sigma
1 plus is the minus state,
and sigma 1 minus
is the plus state.
1 over square root of 2.
Those are things
that you may just
remember sigma 1 is this matrix.
So you get 1 over
square root of 2 plus,
minus, plus, minus, plus.
So that's phi 1.
And phi 1 is
orthogonal to phi 0.
You can see that because plus
minus cannot have an overlap
with plus plus, nor
with minus minus.
Here minus plus, no.
In order to get
something, you would
have to have the same label
here and the same label here
so that something matches.
Well, we can do the
other ones as well.
I will not bother you too
much writing them out.
So what do they look like?
Well, you have phi 2 would
be 1 tensor sigma 2 on phi 0.
And that would give you--
I will just copy it-- an i
because sigma 2 has i's there.
So i over square root of 2
plus, minus, minus, minus, plus.
Finally, phi 3 is 1
tensor sigma 3 phi 0.
And it's 1 over
square root of 2 plus,
plus, minus, minus, minus.
We got the states here.
Let's just check
they're orthonormal.
Well, here's one thing.
If you take phi 0 with
1 tensor sigma i phi 0,
which is phi 0 with phi i.
Well, this is 0.
You could say, well,
how do you know?
How do you prove it easily?
Well, I think the best
way is just inspection,
so let's look at that.
Phi 1, we said, is
orthogonal to phi 0
because it has plus
minus and minus plus,
and that can never do
anything with that.
Phi 2 also has plus
minuses and minus pluses,
so we can never have
anything to do with phi 0.
The only one that
has a chance to have
an inner product
with phi 0 is phi 2
because it has a plus
plus and a minus minus.
On the other hand,
when you flip them,
this term with a plus plus
of phi 0 will give you 1,
but here's a difference of sign.
So this with the second term of
phi 00 will give you a minus,
and therefore, it will be 0.
So these things are
all 0 by inspection.
You don't really have to
do a calculation there.
The one that takes
a little more work
is to try to understand what
is the inner product of phi i
with phi j.
Now, you could say, OK, I'm
going to do them by inspection.
After all, there's just
six things to check.
But let's just do it a
little more intelligently.
Let's try to calculate this by
saying, well, this is phi 0.
Since the Pauli
matrices are Hermitian,
this phi i is also
1 tensor sigma i.
They're Hermitian, so
acting on the left,
they're doing the right thing.
Given our definition, here
is a definition as well.
So you take the bra
and that's what it is.
It would have been dagger
here but it's not necessary.
And then you have the phi j,
which is 1 tensor sigma j.
And that's phi 0 here.
That sounds like
the kind of thing
that we can make progress
using our Pauli identities.
Indeed, first thing is that
the product of operators, they
multiply just in that order
in the tensor product.
So phi 0, you have 1 times 1,
which is 1 tensor sigma i sigma
j phi 0.
And this is equal
to phi 0 1 tensor.
Now, the product of
two Pauli matrices
gives you an identity
plus a Pauli matrix.
You may or may not remember
this formula, but it's 1 times
delta ij plus i epsilon
ijk sigma k phi 0.
Now, what do we get?
Look, the second term
has a sigma k on phi 0,
so it's some number
with a psi k here,
while the first
term is very simple.
What do we get from
the first term?
From the first term,
we get-- well, 1 tensor
1 between any two things
is nothing because the 1
acting on things and the 1
acting on another thing is 0.
So the unit operator in the
tensor product is 1 tensor 1.
That's nothing whatsoever.
So what do you get here?
Delta ij times phi 0 phi 0
plus i epsilon ijk phi 0 phi k.
But that is 0.
We already showed that
any phi i with phi 0 is 0.
And this is 1.
So what have we learned?
That this whole
thing is delta ij.
And therefore, the
basis is orthonormal.
So we've got a basis
of orthonormal states
in the tensor product of
two spin 1/2 particles.
And the nice thing
about this basis
is that all of these basis
states are entangled states.
They're entangled
because they fill
different parts of the matrix.
Here you have 1 and
1 and minus 1 here.
This would be plus minus, would
be an i here and a minus i
there.
The determinants are
non-zero for all of them,
and therefore, they
can't be factored,
and therefore,
they're entangled.
So the last thing I
want to do with this
is to record a
formula for you, which
is a formula of the basis
states in the conventional way,
written as superposition
of entangled states.
So for example, you
say, what is plus plus?
Well, plus plus, looking
there, how would you solve it?
You would solve it
from phi 0 and phi 3.
You would take the sum so that
the minus minus states cancel.
Phi 0 and phi 3, and
therefore, this state
must be 1 over square root
of 2, phi 0 plus phi 3.
A useful relation.
Then we have plus minus.
Then we have minus plus.
And finally, minus minus.
Well, minus minus
would be done by 1
over square root of
2 phi 0 minus phi 3.
The other ones, well, they
just leave complex numbers.
Phi 1 has this plus minus, and
this has a plus minus in phi 2.
The only problem is
it has an i, so you
must take this state
minus i times this state
will produce this state twice
and will cancel this term.
That's what you want.
So phi 1, this should be 1 over
square root of 2 phi 1 minus i
phi 2.
And this one should
be phi 1 plus i phi 2.
And if this was a
little quick, it's
just algebra, one more line.
You do it with
patience in private.
So here it is.
It's the normal product,
simple product basis expressed
as a superposition
of entangled states.
This is called the bell
basis, this phi 1 up to phi 4,
the bell basis.
And now, I have to say
a couple more things
and we're on our way to begin
the teleportation thing.
Are there questions?
Any questions about bell basis
or the basis we've introduced?
Any confusion?
Errors on the blackboard?
So we have a basis, and I want
to make two remarks before we
get started with
the teleportation.
It's one remark
about measurement
and one remark about
evolution of states.
Two facts.
The first fact has to
do with measurement
in orthonormal basis.
If you have an
orthonormal basis,
the postulate of measurement
of quantum mechanics
can be stated as
saying that you can
do an experiment
in which you find
the probability of your state
being along any of these basis
states of the orthonormal basis.
So you can do an
experiment to detect
in which of the basis
states the state is.
Now, the state, of course,
is in a superposition
of basis states, but it will
collapse into one of them
with some probability.
So the Stern-Gerlach
experiment was an example
in which you pick two
basis states, orthogonal,
and there was a
device that allowed
you to collapse the state
into one or the other.
So this is a little
more general, not just
for two state systems.
If there would be a
particle with three states,
well, orthonormal
states, then there
is in principle an operator
in quantum mechanics
that allows it to measure
which of these basis states
you go into.
So let me state this as saying,
given an orthonormal basis, e1
up to en, we can
measure a state, psi,
and we get that the probability
to be in ei is, as you know,
ei overlapped with
a state squared.
And if you measure
that this probability,
the state will collapse
into one of these states.
So after the measurement,
the state goes into some ek.
There are different
probabilities
to be in each one of
those basis states,
but the particle
will choose one.
Now, the other thing
I want to mention
is that a fact that has
seemed always a gift,
the Pauli matrices are
not only Hermitian,
but they square to one, and
therefore they're also unitary.
So the Pauli
matrices are unitary.
So actually, they can be
realized as time evolution.
So you have a state and you
want to multiply it by sigma 1.
You say, OK, well, that's
a very mathematical thing.
Not so mathematical because
it's a unitary operator,
so it could respond to
some time evolution.
So we claim there
is a Hamiltonian
that you can construct
that will evolve the state
and multiply it by sigma 1.
So all these Pauli matrices,
sigma 1, sigma 2, and sigma 3
are unitary as operators.
They can be realized
by time evolution
with a suitable Hamiltonian.
So if you're
talking spin states,
some magnetic field
that lifts for some few
picoseconds according to
the dipole, and that's it.
It will implement sigma one.
Just in fact, you can
check, for example,
that e to the i pi over
2 minus 1 plus sigma i.
This is i this, and
this is Hermitian.
Well, this is 1 and sigma i.
1 and sigma i
commute, so this is
equal to e to the
minus i pi over 2 times
e to the i pi sigma 1 over 2.
The first factor is a minus
i, and the second factor
is 1 times cosine of pi
over 2 plus i sigma 1 sine
of pi over 2.
So this is minus i times--
this is 0-- times i sigma 1.
So this is sigma 1.
So we've written sigma
1 as the exponential
of i times the
Hermitian operator.
And therefore, you
could say that this
must be equal to some time times
some Hamiltonian over h bar.
And you decide, you
put the magnetic field
in the x, y, z direction.
You realize it.
So sigmas can be
realized by a machine.
We're all done with our
preliminary remarks,
and it's now time to do
the teleportation stuff.
Quantum teleportation.
So we all know
this teleportation
is the stuff of science
fiction and movies
and kind of stuff like that, and
it's pretty much something that
was, classically,
essentially impossible.
You have an object, you sort of
dematerialize it and create it
somewhere else.
No basis for doing that.
The interesting thing is
that quantum mechanically,
you seem to be able
to do much better,
and that's the idea that
we want to explain now.
So this is also
not something that
has been known for a long time.
The big discovery that this
could be done is from 1993.
So it's just 20 years ago
people realized finally
that you could do
something like that.
In that way, quantum
mechanics is, in a sense,
having a renaissance
because there's
all kinds of marvelous
experiments-- teleportation,
entanglement, ideas that you
could build one day a quantum
computer.
It's all stimulating
thinking better
about quantum mechanics
more precisely,
and the experiments
are just amazing.
This thing was done by
the following people.
We should mention them.
Bennett at IBM,
Brassard, Crepeau--
can't pronounce that-- Jozsa,
all these people in Montreal.
Peres, at Technion, and
Wootters at Williams College.
1993.
So big collaboration
all over the world.
So what is the question
that we want to discuss?
In this game, always
there's two people involved,
and the canonical names
are Alice and Bob.
Everybody calls Alice and Bob.
It's been lots of
years that people
talk about Alice and Bob.
They use it also for
black hole experiments.
Depending on your
taste, Alice stays out
and Bob is sucked into the
black hole, or Bob stays out,
Alice goes down.
But it's Alice and
Bob all the time.
So this time, the way
we're going to do it,
Alice has a quantum state.
It has been handed
to her, and it's
a state of a spin 1/2 particle.
Spin 1/2 is nice because
you have discrete labels.
So she has this state.
It's alpha plus beta minus.
And she has it carefully
there in a box, just
hoping that the state doesn't
get entangled with anything
and disappear, or
doesn't get measured.
And her goal is to send this
state to Bob, who's far away.
So Alice is sitting
here and has this state,
and Bob is sitting somewhere
here and has no state.
And she wants to
send this state.
This is the state
to be teleported.
Now, there's a
couple of things you
could try to do before even
trying to teleport this.
Why teleport it?
Why don't you create a
copy of this state and just
put it in FedEx and send
it to Bob, and he gets it?
The problem is that there's
something in quantum mechanics,
something called no
cloning, that you
can't create a copy
of a state, actually,
with a quantum
mechanical process.
It's really a funny thing.
You've got a qubit-- this is
called a qubit-- a quantum bit.
Bit is something
that can be 0 or 1.
Quantum, it can be two things.
So instead of calling
it a spin state,
sometimes people
call it a qubit.
For us, it's a spin state.
It has two numbers.
And there's no cloning.
We will not discuss it here.
It's a nice topic
for a recitation.
It's a simple matter.
You can't make a copy.
So given that you can't make
a copy, let's avoid that idea,
save ourselves $15 of FedEx and
just try to do something else.
So the one thing
Alice could do is
that she could say, all right.
Well here is alpha and beta.
Let me measure the state.
Find alpha and beta.
And then I'll of send
that information to Bob.
OK.
But she has one
copy of the state.
How is she going to
measure alpha and beta
with one copy of the state.
She puts it through a
Stern-Gerlach experiment,
and the particle comes
out the plus side.
Now what?
The probability that
it went to the plus.
You've got some information
about the alpha squared.
Not even because you just
did the experiment once
and your cubit is gone.
So Alice actually can't
figure out alpha and beta.
So if she's handed the qubit,
she better not measure it.
Because if she measures
it, she destroys the state,
goes into a plus or a
minus, and it's all over.
The state is gone before
she could do anything.
So that doesn't work either.
Now there's the third option.
Maybe Alice cannot talk to Bob,
and Alice created that state
with some Hamiltonian.
And she knows because
she created it
what alpha and beta is.
So she could in
principle tell Bob, OK.
Here is alpha and here is beta.
Create it again.
That would be a fine
strategy, but actually there's
even plausibly a
problem with that.
Because maybe she knows this
state, but alpha is a number.
It is 0.53782106, never ends.
Doesn't repeat.
And she has to send that
infinite string of information
to Bob, which is not
a good idea either.
She's not going to manage
to send the right state.
So these are the things
we speculate about
because it's a natural
thing to one wonder.
So what we're going to
try to do is somehow
produce an experiment in
which she'll take this state,
get it in, and
somehow Bob is going
to create that state
on his other side.
That's the teleportation
thing that we'll try to do.
So let's do a little diagram
of how we're going to do this.
So here is going to be the state
that is going to be teleported.
We'll call it the
state C. So I'll
write it as psi alpha plus in
the state space C sub particle
plus beta minus in this
state space C. And C is
the state she is going
to try to teleport.
But now they're not
going to be able to do it
unless they use
something different.
They try something different.
And the whole idea is going to
be to use an entangled state.
So basically what
we're going to do
is we're going to put the source
here, entangled state source.
And we're going to
produce and an entangled
state of two particles.
And one particle is going
to be given to A, to Alice.
And one particle is
going to be given to Bob.
So particle B for Bob is
And particle A is going
to be given to Alice.
And this is an entangled pair.
So there it is.
Now what's going to happen?
What are we going to do?
Entanglement really
correlates what
goes here with
what goes in there.
Now entanglement
happens instantaneously,
and we can discuss this.
You have no way of
sending information
through entanglement in general.
There's no such thing as
learning something about A when
B doesn't measure, learning
anything nontrivial about A.
So the entangled state
is there, and that's
what we're going to try to use
in order to do the teleporting.
Now morally speaking, suppose
I wanted to teleport myself
from one place in
this room to another.
What I would have to do is
create an enormous reservoir
of entangled states.
So here's my
generator, and I create
billions of entangled pairs.
And I put them all
here, all the ones here
and all the corresponding
pairs over there.
And then I sort
of-- somebody takes
me and these billions of
entangled pairs, one side
of the pair, and
does a measurement
in which every atom or every
quantum state in my body
is measured with
some entangled state.
They've done the
measurement, and boom.
I reappear on the other side.
That's what's going to happen.
So we're going to do this.
We're going to have this
state, and now we're
going to a measurement between
this state and this state.
Alice is going to
do a measurement.
That's going to
force this particle
to actually pretty much
become the state you
wanted to teleport.
So that's the goal.
So let me say a
couple more things.
Alice will have to send
some information actually.
Because she is going to have
to do a measurement, and she
has a console with four lights,
zero, one, two, and three.
Four lights.
And when she will do her
measurement, one of the lights
will blink.
And she will have to tell
Bob which one blinked.
So she will have to send the
number and information of two
bits.
Because with two bits,
you can represent
any of four numbers,
binary code.
So she will send information
of which clicked.
And then Bob will have a
machine with four entries here.
And according to the
information that he gets,
he will make the state
to go through one
of those machines, the zero,
the one, the two, or the three.
So he will push B
into one of them out,
we claim, will come
this teleported state.
So that's the set up.
You have to get a
feel for the set up.
So are there questions
on what we're doing?
AUDIENCE: So after
teleportation would
have some kind of
copy [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: No.
After the replication,
this state
will be destroyed beyond
repair as you will see.
So there will not be a copy
created by this procedure.
You destroy.
It's really what teleportation
was supposed to be.
Not to create another
copy of you there,
but to take you there.
Destroy you here and
recreate you there.
So no other copy.
Other questions?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Does this also work
if C is an entangled state?
PROFESSOR: If what?
AUDIENCE: If C say itself
contains different parts which
are entangled with each other?
PROFESSOR: Well, it's a
more complicated thing.
I'm pretty sure it would work.
Maybe you would need more
than one entangled pair here.
You would need a source
that is more complicated.
More questions.
AUDIENCE: What do you mean
about pushes the state
into one of the [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: What do I mean by
pushes it through one of them?
Well you know, Hamiltonians.
You get your state.
You can put them in
a magnetic field.
Let them evolve a little bit.
Those are machines.
So any of these machines are
some unitary time evolution.
It does something to the state.
AUDIENCE: But one [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Sorry.
AUDIENCE: Are there
Hamiltonians that
are based off of
what Alice measures?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
So they will be correlated
as you will see.
So if Alice measures that
the light zero beeps,
the instruction for Bob is to
send the state through the zero
Hamiltonian, and one, two,
and three Hamiltonian.
More questions?
It's good to really have
a good feeling of this
or what we're trying to do
and why it's nontrivial.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: This might be
a little too intuitive,
but in a state which-- Can a
Hamiltonian which Bob needs
to send B through in order to
yield the same state that Alice
had, can that also be
transmitted quantumly
through qubits?
Or would you just get like an
infinite line of qubits needing
to--
PROFESSOR: No no.
You know, this is a devise that
they can build by themselves.
As you will see once
we do the calculation,
Alice will construct a device
that has these four lights
and she knows what they mean.
And Bob will construct a
device that has these things,
and they can use it to
transport any state.
So these machines are
independent of the state
you want to teleport.
You teleported this, you want
to teleport another state
with alpha prime and beta prime?
Sure.
Use exactly the same machines,
give me another entangled pair,
and do it.
AUDIENCE: Well, I
think what I meant
is that the information
between the two machines,
does that have to be
transmitted classically,
or is there some
way to transmit--
PROFESSOR: There's
no real information.
The machines were built, say,
in the same laboratory of IBM.
And then they're built,
and we will tell you
how to build each
of these machines.
And then just put aside, taken
away by these two people,
and then we'll do it.
There's no mystery of
sending information about it.
That probably will become
clear with the computation,
which I better start doing soon.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: The difference--
PROFESSOR: Louder.
AUDIENCE: Just a question
about the first part
on the left side of the board.
So, when we first
do a measurement,
does that mean it's
something that's
like a microscopic quantity,
like an energy or something?
Or does it just refer to any?
PROFESSOR: When we refer
to measurements and quantum
mechanics, we talk--
Let me give you
just a little bit
of intuition here.
We typically talk about
measuring permission operators,
because they have
[INAUDIBLE] values.
So we don't have to say what
they are-- energy, momentum.
It's a permission
operator you measure.
And projector operators
into basic states
of permission operators.
So you could imagine
that's one way
of thinking about
these measurements.
OK.
So let's do this.
All right.
The state to be
teleported is this one,
and the A B pair is
an entangled state.
So it will be one
of the bell states,
psi zero AB 1 over square
root of 2 plus A plus
b plus minus A plus minus B. So
this is the state they share.
Of course, Alic only has
a handle on particle A,
and Bob only has a handle
on particle B. Nevertheless
the state is entangled
even though this
could be 200 kilometers apart.
So the total state-- well,
we've been tensoring two things.
Well, tensoring three
is three particles.
So I don't think you will be
too unhappy to just tensor
the whole thing.
So psi zero AB tensor alpha
plus C plus beta minus C.
So here comes the
interesting point.
Alice has available the state A.
The particle A is not the state
A because A is in a funny thing.
It's entangled.
But it has a
particle A available,
and it has a
particle C available.
So Alice is going
to do a measurement,
and it's going to be
a sneaky measurement.
It's going to use a bases.
Since she has two
particles, she can
choose a basis of
two particle states.
Any orthonormal basis
will do well by the idea
that we can measure with
any orthonormal basis.
So what she's going
to try to do is use
the bell basis for A and C.
So let's try to think
of what that means.
That requires a small
calculation here.
So this is equal to 1
over square root of 2
plus-- so I anticipate
that this will become clear
in a second, what that
measurement means-- plus minus
A minus b Tensor alpha plus plus
beta minus C. So I just wrote
what this is.
OK.
Some algebra.
This is the total
state, psi total.
Let's multiply these things
out, and I will keep the labels
all the time
because I don't want
there to be any confusion
about what's happening.
So what do we get first?
Alpha multiplying plus of A.
I should write in plus of B,
but the order doesn't really
matter if I keep the labels.
So I'll put plus of
C times plus of B.
Then keep multiplying.
So we have plus beta,
from this with that.
So I'll have plus of A minus
of C and plus of B. Maybe
it's easier to read
if I use another line.
So I now must multiply the
second state times this.
So I get plus alpha minus of A
with plus of C and minus of B.
So this is this times that,
minus of A plus of C minus of B
plus beta minus of A
minus of C minus of B.
OK.
So there here my state.
But now I have written it in a
way that I have here A and C A
and C A and C and
A and C. So I could
decide to measure in this basis.
This is an orthonormal
basis for A and C.
But it's not a very smart basis
because it's not entangled.
So let's go to the
entangled base.
So let's rewrite this
state, this total state.
Nothing has been done
yet to the state.
We're just mathematically
rewriting it, nothing else.
We have this, this,
this, and that.
And I want you now to use
these formulas to do this.
So I'll do this on
this blackboard.
We'll have to erase
those important names.
So what do we get?
Well a little of algebra.
Let's do it.
A with C plus plus
would be that.
So I'll write it with
one over square root of 2
becomes one half.
A with C would be psi zero AC
plus psi three AC multiplying
alpha plus on B. So I took
care of the first term.
The alpha is there.
The B is there.
And AC is there,
in which, you know,
you can put any labels
you want to here.
AB, this is the AB state.
The entangled AB state.
We used AC.
Second term plus one half.
Now we have plus A minus C. So
it's the second line in there.
So it would be psi one AC minus
I psi 2 AC beta plus B. Next
line, I'll just
copy it, one half.
Well not.
Alpha minus B and here
you'll have the minus plus
which is the same thing,
psi 1 AC plus I psi 2 AC.
And the last term is plus one
half psi 0 AC minus psi 3 AC.
And we get beta minus B.
OK, almost was there.
Let's rewrite this as-- let's
collect the psi zeroes, psi 0
and psi 0.
You see we're do nothing yet.
We're just
mathematically rewriting
the states in a different
basis, the total states.
So it is equal to
one half psi 0 AC.
and look what you get
here, very curiously.
You get alpha plus B plus beta
minus B. Very curious, that
was precisely the state
we wanted to teleport.
Alpha plus plus beta minus.
All right.
Let's see what else happens.
Here we get plus
one half psi-- which
other one do I want to copy?
Psi 1 AC.
You see this is the state
we wanted to teleport.
It's here.
And it sort of has
appeared in the B space.
Psi 1 AC, well this time I
have this term and this term.
So actually it seems
a little different.
Now we get beta plus
B plus alpha minus B.
Then we go to the next.
One half of psi 2 AC.
So psi 2 is here.
So you get I alpha minus
B minus I beta plus B. OK.
Finally linear combinations.
And finally psi 3.
What is psi 3?
Well two terms also for psi 3.
This one and this one.
So you get alpha
plus B minus beta
minus B. Kind of the
end of math by now.
You've proven a funny identity
actually in doing this.
And maybe this
blackboard should--
to make sure you understand.
This is the calculation
of total state.
And here we go.
So let me show you one thing.
This is actually
the state we wanted.
So this will be called psi in
the B basis, in the B space.
The state that you
wanted to teleport
that was psi in the C basis,
now it's psi in the B basis.
Those ones look a little
funny, but this one actually
looks like this thing, looks
like sigma 3 times psi.
Because if you have
sigma 3 on this state,
it gives you a plus 1 here
and a minus [INAUDIBLE] value.
So that's sigma 3 psi.
This actually has flipped
the plus and the minus.
So that actually is sigma 1 psi.
And this state is
actually sigma 2 psi.
OK everything is in place now.
We've just done math, but
now comes the physics.
Alice is going to measure in
the bell space of A and C.
So these are the
four bases states.
So she's going to measure in
one of these bases states.
And as see measures, she
falls and the wave function
of her collapses
into one of them.
So when she gets the zero
basis state, this light blanks.
If doing the measurement
on AC, because she
has both particles
A and C, she gets
this basis state-- recall the
postulate of measurement--
light one blinks.
If she gets the third like
2 and the fourth here.
Suppose the state
light zero shines.
Well the state
collapsed into this.
She is now sitting
with psi 0 AC that
has no memory whatsoever
of the original state C,
but B is sitting
with this state,
the state we wanted to teleport.
So if light zero
shines, she tells
Bob, let it go to
machine zero where
there's no magnetic
field, nothing.
So actually the
same state goes out.
If she gets psi 1 as
the measured state,
again no memory in this
state about alpha and beta.
But Bob gets sigma 1 psi 1.
So he puts it into the first
Hamiltonian for a picosecond,
produces a sigma 1.
This Hamiltonian, this
box I takes a state
into sigma I state.
It's a unitary operation.
So puts a sigma 1 and gets psi.
If light two shines,
goes to the machine two,
which produces a sigma 2,
and so he gets the state.
Light four shines, the third
Hamiltonian, he gets the state.
Any of the four options,
he gets the precise state.
The state has been teleported.
You needed to send only the
information of which light
shone, and the state is on
the other side of the ocean.
All right.
That's it for today.